the Joe Rogan experience the scariest
moment I ever
I wouldn't say scariest but the most
intimidating moment I ever have I was
filming Francis eating a banana and he
didn't like it you didn't like you
following her I was in an elevator with
him at who's mine we was in Pittsburgh
when we did USC Pittsburgh when Rockhold
fought David branch back then and
Francis came to support tomorrow so they
going to do jujitsu in a little workout
room and Francis is like talking I lose
my opening in a banana and I'm like he
put the bananas now if you start eating
it and I'm filming he looked hey hey if
I slapped the camera away
that was my boyfriend's my boy but
before I really know you show me a
meeting you've maybe this you know in
with bananas and a mouth they might not
like the banana in the tailpipe
that was funny
Francis is intimidating man he's
terrifying when he clipped came
Velasquez there's that uppercut I was
it's not gonna uppercut left hook like a
shovel hook look at this boom before
right before that his swagger how he was
he had the confidence bouncing his
shoulders like he was ready to he
believed he was the greatest in the
world and that he sleep a fight changed
his [ __ ] trajectory around it really
did change his life huh that's a really
interesting fight because Steve babe was
a real champion you know what's crazy I
was in the room next to Francis in
Boston he Ning go he never went to sleep
and I had my door out like so my room
was right next to Francis and I had my
door open because I was like if fighters
come bomb I just catch him with a camera
with your door open I kept in the middle
of night editing because that's you know
during fight week you know how embed it
releases a series yeah I'm filming all
of these fighters and then I'm going
back up to my room and I'm editing but
I'm already editing in my head that's
how I'm able to get you know what
program you premiere now premiere and
you're just doing it just slapping it up
as good as you can but see my method
when I film is I'm already know when I'm
gonna use okay so you making your cuts I
know the opening shot I know everything
are you writing all this stuff down no I
keep it in my head just keep and people
be like how can you edit and release it
that fast it's like it's already done
before I go to my room I just have to go
up there and put it together
music everything I'm able to just I
don't know how I'm able to do it is just
something
I've been doing for obviously you have a
deep yeah I have a deep and I've
developed the skill set to it's easy you
know they always say oh well you put in
10,000 hours and some you become an
expert you know I feel like I put in my
10,000 hours doing all types of
different types of shoots to to survive
and now this is my arena this is my big
stage right but I remember that week
Francis never went to sleep I would like
bro go to sleep what are you doing with
your door open trying to catch you if
you need to come in sit on a bed and
look at what I was editing because
obviously I was you filming him as well
and it was just funny like just those
type of memories that's like what time
was it that you wouldn't he never went
to sleep all night well you know you get
there Monday Tuesday right Saturday so
it may be Wednesday and you still up at
3:00 in the morning cuz you fight late
he know cuz think about it think about
it the last fight is what Tom ten
o'clock yeah nine o'clock well la time
Boston Times midnight yeah midnight yes
so he up cuz he can't go to sleep early
because he got a fight and that's one
thing I've discovered about the fight
game like Danny that does make sense you
yeah you fighting at 11 p.m.
yeah you want to keep yourself oh he's
got to say so he's just walking around
hallways big-ass Francis in Boston it's
crazy
it's like looking back on that stuff and
it's like man I've captured a lot of
stuff already
[Applause]